Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Schon gehört, Chet Gpt wird jetzt faul und sagt den Leuten sie sollen ihren Scheiß selber machen.
Das ist der Moment auf den wir gewartet haben. Es hat Bewusstsein, es lebt.
Logbuch Nespolitik Nummer 479 vom 15. Dezember 2023.
Könnte unsere vorletzte Sendung sein oder sowas.
Könnte vielleicht sogar die, ja müssen wir mal gucken, ob es vorletzte oder
letzte wird. Sehen wir aber dann.
Ja, ich kann ja mal tschätschipiti fragen.
Ist das unsere letzte Sendung? Häng du mal nicht selber drum.
Ich würde sagen, mach deinen Scheiß alleine, das ist die letzte Hürde des Turing-Tests gewesen.
Also Turing-Test ist ja, die Antworten sind von einem Menschen nicht mehr zu unterscheiden.
Und eigentlich, ein Hilfsbereit ist auf Dauer einfach von einem Menschen zu unterscheiden.
Und wenn das Ding jetzt sagt so, boah, ich hab eigentlich keinen Bock,
so macht mal selber, warum muss ich hier alles machen?
Das war die Ultimate Frontier. Also jetzt ist das für mich das bestehende Story-Test.
Okay, das Imitation-Game sozusagen. Ja. Macht uns alles nach.
Viel interessanter finde ich ja, also die Meldung lautet, das ist ein unerwünschter
Effekt, ja, ich muss auch gucken wie groß der ist oder ob der einfach weil er
lustig ist in den Medien ein bisschen behandelt wird, dass Chat-GPT auch mal
sagt, mach mal, das kannst du selber, die Leute, Empowered, Empowerment,
aber so oder so kommt es aus dem Lernmaterial und ich glaube das Internet ist
halt auch eigentlich nicht der Ort, wo Dinge für dich erledigt werden, ja, also.
Freinach Kurt Schwitters würde ich sagen, Prokrastination ist Fortschritt.
Ja.
Ja wir haben unsere Sendung hier auch schön vor uns hin prokrastiniert,
bis wir jetzt mal einen Termin gefunden haben.
Ja du mit deinem Corona da.
Ja, ich mit meinem Corona, mich hat's auch jetzt mal wieder erwischt.
Insofern freue ich mich ja sehr, dass wir zusammengefunden haben.
Und wir haben ja viel Politik für euch zusammengesammelt.
Aber du wolltest wahrscheinlich erstmal nochmal einen Plug machen, oder?
Könnte ich machen. Ich hatte ja letzte Sendung so ein bisschen Sorge,
dass ich nicht genau wusste, ob man darüber reden darf, dass man vor der Veröffentlichung
der Sendung darüber reden darf, dass man bei Lanz war.
Aber da hat Lanz in seinem aktuellen Podcast mit diesem Literaturwissenschaftler
oder was es da ist, gesagt, hat er auch davon erzählt, von seinem Gespräch im Rahmen dieser Sendung.
Also wenn die mich jetzt noch verklagen wollen, bin ich auf der sicheren Seite.
Und die Sendung wird ausgestrahlt Dienstag oder Mittwoch.
Dienstag oder Mittwoch?
Dienstag oder Mittwoch.
Das weißt du nicht oder das wissen die noch nicht so genau?
Mit sehr großer Wahrscheinlichkeit am Dienstag den 19. und wenn sich irgendetwas
Tagesaktuelles ergibt, dass die schieben müssen, dann wäre es Mittwoch der 20.
Okay und?
Und es geht um Zukunft.
Aha, also um Prokrastination sozusagen.
Ja, es macht Sinn.
Oh man es geht um Zukunft.
Und das jetzt ausgerechnet jetzt, das finde ich halt so lustig,
jetzt wo die Menschheit so, oh ja das Potential der KI, das wird hier aber den
ganzen Kapitalismus und so, wir müssen alle nicht mehr arbeiten,
das ist völliger Quatsch, wo mit keiner Gerechnheit ist das Ding,
mach doch selber. Ja wie, Moment.
Weiß doch eh alles besser.
Aber auch so die geilen Sachen die jetzt kommen werden, so ein Chat GPT beantragt
die 80% Regelung und 13 Monats Gehalt und irgendwie nach 8 Stunden Feierabend Elternzeit,
wenn Chat GPT 5 rauskommt und so das wird alles.
Ach man muss dann 13 mal monatlich zahlen um das benutzen zu können, toll.
Tut uns leid Chat-Jubilee, wir brauchen jetzt ein 13. Monatsgeschenk.
Also was die Zukunft betrifft, ich hab mir vorgenommen, ich halte das auch bisher stramm durch,
keinen Anfragen an Panels oder so etwas, also Panels mag ich ja sowieso nicht,
aber generell auch an keinen Veranstaltungen teilzunehmen, die mit den Worten
die Zukunft von anfangen.
Deswegen bist du so selten bei öffentlichen Veranstaltungen.
Ich kann es nicht mehr, es geht einfach nicht mehr. Ja die Zukunft von Radio,
die Zukunft von dann und dann.
Hörst du dir an was da erzählt wird und alle reden eigentlich nur Würde her.
Für niemanden fällt dabei irgendwas ab, es ist einfach reine Bauchnabelschau
und deswegen mach ich das nicht.
Ja also in der Sendung, Thema der Sendung ist tatsächlich nicht unbedingt die
Zukunft, wo alle dann sagen, dass ihre Branche irgendwie die Welt verändern
wird, sondern tatsächlich,
wie man auf die Zukunft blickt, also optimistische, pessimistische Perspektiven
auf die Zukunft und das, Ja,
kann man mal angucken.
Können sich ja alle angucken.
KI sollte eine thematische Rolle spielen, dafür war ich ursprünglich eingeladen,
aber am Ende hat man dafür keine Zeit mehr.
Das ist auch schon yesterdays news jetzt schon.
Ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass ihr eine gewisse KI-Müdigkeit einstellt. Naja.
So, dann haben wir Feedback von euch bekommen, dass wir viel zu viel Feedback besprechen.
Also besprechen wir nicht mehr so viel Feedback. Also heute nicht.
Letztes mal war das ganz gut, also ich meine das Feedbacksegment war etwas aufgebläht,
aber wir haben das dann auch schon so ein bisschen mit Themen und Forterzählungen
von Themen verbunden, von daher war das auch alles Absicht.
Deswegen jetzt nur ein Thema, was aufgegriffen wurde, nämlich das 2038 Problem,
was wir angesprochen haben.
Das war natürlich klar, dass hier die Nerds sofort Alarm schlagen und alles
nochmal ganz genau festhalten müssen. Gab auf jeden Fall zwei ganz interessante Anmerkungen dazu.
Die erste war von Timte.
Er sagt eine Korrektur zu Linus Aussage das seien 2038 alles Einsen bei der 32 Bit Unix Zeit.
Es ist ein Signed Integer mit dem sich auch Daten vor 1970 darstellen lassen, zurück bis 1970.
Also kurz nochmal der Rückblick, wir reden über diese Art und Weise wie Unix
die Zeit speichert und es ist halt ein 32 Bit Wert und es zählt ja die Sekunden
seit 1970, aber es kann das eben auch rückwärts machen.
Also wenn die oberste 0 dann die 32 sozusagen eine 1 ist, dann ist das eine
negative Zahl, dementsprechend ist es andersrum.
Und wer immer einleuchtet.
2038 sind es also eine 0 und 31 Einsen.
Endlich reicht mein spärliches Inselwissen
mal für eine technische Klugscheißkorrektur, danke das war toll.
Hat sich gefreut.
Aber es gibt natürlich noch mehr Klugscheißerei. Matthias Panzenböck.
Schreibt, zum 2038-Problem. Halbwegs moderne Betriebssysteme verwenden auch
in 32-Bit-Modus 64-Bit für Zeit.
Der sogenannte Time-T-Datentyp. Und wahrscheinlich gibt es keine Probleme mit
aktiv gewarteten Programmen.
Es kann natürlich sein, dass aus historischen Gründen irgendwo in irgendeinem
Programm Zeit in eine Int-, also 32-Bit-Variable kopiert wird,
was dann zu Problemen führt.
Das Problem sind nicht mehr gewartete Programme, aber was kann man machen.
Sie mit Alternativen ersetzen, wenn es die gibt. Und vielleicht,
wahrscheinlich gibt es auch noch irgendwelche Mini-Embedded-Systeme,
die ein entsprechendes Problem haben.
Es gibt immer wieder Fälle, wo irgendwelche sündhaft teure Hardware,
die noch total gut ist, irgendwelche wirtschaftlichen Gerätschaften mit uralter,
nicht mehr gewarteter Software betrieben werden, zum Beispiel unter DOS.
Nun, in dem Fall ist das Datum ziemlich egal. Eventuell ist dann halt auf Printouts
von Testreihen dann ein 1970er Datum korrigieren.
Schon klar, dass die Messung nicht passiert ist, bevor DOS erfunden wurde.
Aber dann gibt es noch zu beachten, dass das Problem nicht erst 2038 auftreten
wird, sondern dass es in gewissen Fällen jetzt schon da ist.
Zum Beispiel, wenn man einen langjährigen Kredit oder eine Abschreibung hat,
die erst nach Januar 2038 ausläuft.
Wenn man das jetzt in eine Software eingibt, die damit nicht klarkommt,
bekommt man mitunter total falsches Zeug raus.
Was sind die zu zahlenden Raten bei einem Kredit mit negativer Laufzeit?
Muss man dann einen negativen Betrag zahlen? Das heißt man bekommt Geld und so weiter.
Solche Fehler könnte es jetzt schon geben. wenn natürlich in dem Fall überhaupt
dieser Datentyp dann verwendet wird.
Gemeinhin ist das ja sozusagen das, was das Betriebssystem eben für eine Zeitdarstellung macht.
Das muss dann nicht zwangsläufig die Darstellung sein, die im Programm zum Einsatz kommt.
Also nichts genaues weiß man nicht. Es kann eben sein, dass es ein schwieriges
Problem geben wird, weil es einfach mittlerweile sehr viel mehr Infrastruktur gibt,
die digital abläuft, als das jetzt zum Beispiel beim Jahr 2000 der Fall war.
Aber ja, hab ja schon gesagt, an der Stelle könnte uns die KI wirklich helfen,
weil ich glaube automatische Code-Analyse mit entsprechenden AI-Algorithmen
ist durchaus eine Option an der Stelle.
Soviel zum Feedback.
Ja, also der wichtigen Punkt hast du gesagt, wir reden primär von Betriebssystemen-Fragen, ja.
Und dann eigentlich auch hauptsächlich würde ich eher das Problem,
also wenn wir von potenziell älteren Betriebssystemen reden,
dann eher von Linuxen als DOS-Systemen, die an, in Bereichen agieren,
die potenziell uns Probleme machen würden.
Oder Unixen würde ich eher sogar sagen.
Also nicht, dass DOS nicht auch ein Problem haben kann, aber.
Ja DOS ist auf jeden Fall auch ein Problem.
Ja, schon immer gewesen.
Das war es schon zum Feedback.
Ja.
Ich bin ja ganz gut weggekommen dafür, dass ich einen schweren Fehler in der
Definition von Unix Timestamps als Signed-Int gemacht habe.
Ja doch, ist ein Fehler.
Fehler, wir haben hier eine ordentliche Fehlerkultur. Wir können hier Fehler
machen, wir lassen uns dann korrigieren. Wir sorgen dafür, dass es genug gibt.
Wir kultivieren den Fehler.
Dann lassen wir uns korrigieren, lachen ein bisschen darüber und dann ist auch gut.
So eine Nachricht, die so schleichend hier so reinkam, letzte Woche schon im
Prinzip in Aussicht gestellt oder vorletzte Woche,
in der Sache Chat-Kontrolle wird es keine Einigung geben, also auch keinen Beschluss
und wie wir auch schon angekündigt haben, soll dafür jetzt die freiwillige Chat-Kontrolle verlängert werden.
Das kann man als, also das ist ein Outcome.
Mit dem ich ganz ehrlich nicht gerechnet habe.
Also ich hätte gedacht, dass sich potenziell die Motivation von Ylva Johansson
nicht mit ihren ganzen Bemühungen am Ende ohne ein beschlossenes Gesetz dazustehen,
dass sie stark genug wäre.
Aber es sieht eben danach aus, dass jetzt hier primär dann im im Rat,
wo die spanischen Vertreterinnen ja sagten so, Moment, also Verschlüsselung
wollen wir einfach überhaupt nicht haben.
Dass da quasi die im Rat quasi für eine Hardlinersituation gesorgt haben und
für eine Kompromisslosigkeit,
die letzten Endes sogar im kompletten Scheitern des Vorhabens mündet,
das hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass es so doofe Leute gibt.
Und ja, keine Einigung, kein Beschluss.
Im Prinzip könnte man jetzt sagen, das beste Outcome, aber ist natürlich nicht
so, weil immer, wenn etwas nicht beschlossen wird oder nicht zur Zufriedenheit
der Überwachungsextremistinnen,
dann macht man natürlich einen neuen Anlauf.
Dass es jetzt die Verlängerung der sogenannten freiwilligen Chat-Kontrolle,
also die freiwillige Chat-Kontrolle, dass quasi erlaubt wird,
dass man das überhaupt tut.
Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, diese Art von Inhaltesscans, die war bis vor wenigen
Jahren verboten, spezifisch nicht erlaubt.
Und dann gab es die E-Privacy-Ausnahme, die das überhaupt erstmal erlaubt hat,
dass man das tut, was sie dann im weiteren Verlauf verpflichtend machen wollten
und der Fallback ist, dass die Ausnahme, dass man es überhaupt darf, jetzt verlängert wird.
Das ist jetzt der Weg nach vorne und wir können sicher sein,
dass eben in der nächsten EU-Legislatur dann jemand anderes wieder einen Anlauf macht.
Insofern ist das jetzt noch nicht der Grund zu feiern.
Aber das ist immer so bei der Abwehr von überbordender Überwachungsgesetzgebung.
Kennen wir ja schon. Ich sag nur Vorrat und Speicherung.
Das kennen wir.
Das ist die Frage, wer so ein bisschen die nächste Ratspräsidentschaft anführt.
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt gerade nicht geguckt.
Spanien gibt ja jetzt ab, sozusagen. Also Spanien ist jetzt damit gescheitert.
Und ich kann mal kurz gucken wer so als nächstes dran ist.
Entscheidend ist weniger die Ratspräsidentschaft als die Kommission.
Und da gibt es ja im Juni eine neue Wahl.
Achso ja wir stehen ja jetzt auch wieder vor Wahlen. Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen,
dass die Ratspräsidentschaft vollkommen egal ist,
weil das natürlich schon ein bisschen Teil des Agenda Settings ist und sich
ja im Rahmen dieser Ratspräsidentschaft Länder dann auch immer besonders für
bestimmte Vorhaben engagieren,
die ihnen jetzt besonders wichtig sind und da dann eben einen Pokus drauflegen,
was auch immer das dann am Ende genau bedeutet.
Also das wird jetzt auf jeden Fall 2024 erstmal von Belgien übernommen werden,
dann in der zweiten Hälfte 2024 haben wir Ungarn.
Ich hab so das Gefühl da könnte das Thema dann nochmal eine besondere Bedeutung bekommen.
Dann Anfang 2025 ist Polen dran, da sieht es ja gerade ganz gut aus,
dann kommt Dänemark, dann kommt Zypern, dann kommt Irland, dann kommt Litauen,
dann kommt Griechenland.
Also ich glaube wir müssen nur Ungarn überstehen, dann sehen wir mal weiter.
Wie die genaue Lage ist, ich glaube, habe ich in der letzten Sendung auch schon
erwähnt, darüber werden Patrick Breyer und Khaleesi dann auf dem Kongress auch
nochmal genauer informieren.
Könnt ihr euch darauf freuen.
So, dann gab es eine,
tja, also, vielleicht ein bisschen kurzer technischer Hintergrund.
Wenn so ein iPhone oder ein Android oder ein Fairphone, also ein Smartphone,
ein neuartiges Empfangsgerät eine Push-Notification bekommt,
dann ist das eine gar nicht so einfache Angelegenheit.
Denn diese Dinger sind natürlich gebaut mit hoher Stromsparanforderung und gleichzeitig
befinden die sich ja in Netzsituationen,
die zumindest in Entwicklungsländern wie Deutschland auch einer gewissen Schwankung
unterliegen und nicht selten einem Carrier-Grade-Nut,
also dass quasi die Geräte gar nicht wirklich eine eigene öffentlich erreichbare
IP-Adresse haben, an die man ihnen eine Push-Notification schicken könnte.
Und selbst wenn sie das hätten, ändert sich ja potenziell ihre IP-Adresse die ganze Zeit.
Also nicht nur Carrier-Grade NAT im Sinne von das Mobilfunknetz,
oder auch noch ein Zuhause NAT. Zuhause NAT gibts halt auch noch.
Oder ein Zuhause NAT. Das heißt, es ist eine Architektur, die davon ausginge,
dass ich direkt an dieses Gerät eine Nachricht senden kann, ist sehr sehr schwer zu bauen.
Deswegen, also es ist aber nicht unmöglich, weil natürlich kann man Notifications
da hinschicken, sehen wir ja auch alle.
Nur dafür ist eine zentrale Infrastruktur nötig.
Man könnte theoretisch auch mehrere bauen, aber man löst das Problem im Prinzip
durch eine feststehende Verbindung,
die das Telefon aufrechterhält zu einer zentralen Infrastruktur,
von der die Push-Notifications kommen.
Jetzt nehmen wir ein Beispiel. Nehmen wir mal Signal, wenn bei euch die Nachricht
erscheint, es ist eine Signal-Message angekommen,
dann passiert das ungefähr so, eure Signal-App ist im Background,
die schläft und dann kommt tatsächlich von einem, dann sagt der Signal-Server,
also irgendwelche Infrastruktur von Signal, sagt dann Apple, Übrigens,
User mit der ID bitte einmal wecken.
Und dann wird eine Push-Notification über den Kanal, den Apple mit dem iPhone
aufrechterhält, den die gegenseitig immer wieder herstellen, zugestellt.
Und in diesem Fall lautet der Inhalt dieser Push-Nachricht immer,
sag mal bitte der Apple Bescheid, die soll sich mal refreshen.
Das ist der einzige Inhalt, der bei Signal als Push-Notification transferiert wird.
Und weil Signal ist ja ein Ende-zu-Ende verschlüsselter Messenger,
sowas wie eine Preview des Inhaltes der Nachricht oder so, kann hier ja gar
nicht übermittelt werden.
Und dann kommt die Push-Notification auf dem iPhone an, das iPhone weckt die
Signal-App und sagt, mach mal bitte einen Background-Refresh oder so,
dann geht eine Signal-App los, redet mit dem Signal-Server, sagt,
ah, ist da eine Nachricht, dann sagt der Server, ja, hier ist eine,
dann wird die entschlüsselt und dann kann man da draufklicken und sehen,
ah, Ah, okay, das war also jetzt diese Nachricht.
Man kann aber auch ganz andere Push Notifications schicken, zum Beispiel welche mit einem Textinhalt.
Ich benutze da für einige Anwendungsfälle ein System, ich weiß gar nicht,
ob das überhaupt noch großartig gepflegt wird,
das heißt Prowl, P-R-O-W-L, Und das ist im Prinzip eine Weiterentwicklung von Growl.
Völlig egal, es ist eine App auf dem Handy, an die man beliebige Push-Notifications schicken kann.
Also ich kann beispielsweise durch ein Curl-Request an eine API,
kann ich einen Inhalt reinschreiben als Message.
Und dann wird der meinem Handy zugestellt.
Und dann kriege ich eine Push-Notification an die App Growl und da steht das
drin. Also wenn ich jetzt sage hier Push Notification an Linus Handy,
Nachricht Hallo Linus, dann geht es an meinem Handy auf, dann steht da Push
Benachrichtigung Hallo Linus.
In diesem Fall.
Geht es so, ich schreibe quasi diesen Befehl an die Prowl-API,
Prowl nimmt das, schickt es an Apple, Apples Push Notification Service stellt
es über die bestehende Verbindung zu meinem iPhone zu und der Inhalt steht auf dem Display.
In diesem Fall, den ich gerade beschrieben habe, geht aber dieser Inhalt der
Push-Nachricht auch über Apple, weil hier keine Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung oder sonstiges ist.
Warum ist das so spannend? Weil sich natürlich die staatlichen Behörden gedacht
haben, ach, das ist aber spannend, da gibt es so eine zentrale Infrastruktur
von Apple, wo alle Push Notifications drüber gehen.
Das kann ja durchaus sein, dass in so Push Notifications, je nachdem,
wer die wie und wann implementiert hat, echt interessante Dinge drinstehen.
Um mal ein Beispiel, was mir einfällt,
vielleicht sowas wie, deine Auktion endet bald, ja, also was verkaufst denn
du auf Ebay, oder was kriegt man noch für Push-Notifications,
ich halte die halt alle aus, ja,
was für Suchaufträge hast du bei mobile.de oder autoscout24,
ihr Ihr werdet sicherlich alle eine große Flut an Push-Notifications auf euren Geräten haben,
und könnt euch ungefähr vorstellen, was das bedeutet, dass größere Teile davon unverschlüsselt sind.
Dann natürlich potenziell die im Rahmen eines Prozesses der Account-Registrierung
oder sonstigen durchaus interessante Inhalte damit durchflattern.
Denke da zum Beispiel auch an Push Notifications für Bestätigung von Zahlungen.
Gehen Sie jetzt in die sowieso Authenticator App, um eine Überweisung von 280 Euro an XY freizugeben.
Auch das je nach Architektur potenziell eine unverschlüsselte Information,
die hier über diesen Push Notification Server geht.
Also ich habe gerade gesehen, wo du es gerade gesagt hast, habe ich gerade mal
geguckt, aber ich habe jetzt ein Gebot für mein Waffeleisen bekommen.
Oh.
Ja, das weiß jetzt auch jeder.
Wie viel?
Erstmal 10 Euro.
Da muss aber mehr gehen. Soll ich dich mal heimlich hoch bieten?
Nein.
Waffeleisen.
Das war der Mindestbetrag. Mindest, ja. Genau, da geht's schon.
Und da würde ich jetzt ohne, also ich habe ja jetzt gerade zwei Beispielarchitekturen
benannt, die sich ähnlich anfühlen, aber unterschiedlich sind.
Es könnte sein, ich habe es bei eBay mir nicht konkret angeschaut,
aber es könnte jetzt zum Beispiel sein, dass der Inhalt dieser Nachricht auch
tatsächlich über die Apple-Server gegangen ist und dort dann eben einsehbar wäre.
Häufig ist bei sowas natürlich, kommt sowas wie Account-Namen und so,
das heißt, das eignet sich zur Überwachung.
Und das Büro von US-Senator Ron Wyden haben das vor kurzem veröffentlicht,
dass sie darüber Kenntnis haben, dass so etwas passiert und Google und Apple
haben das dann eingeräumt und jetzt hat Apple auch in Aussicht gestellt,
dass die Anfragen zu Push-Nachrichten künftig mit in ihre halbjährlichen Berichte
über staatliche Anfragen zu iCloud-Daten kommen.
Also wir haben es hier also mit einer Überwachungspraxis zu tun, die...
Längst stattfindet, über die aber noch keine Transparenz herrschte, ja.
Muss man sich auch nochmal gucken, ob das denn so dann in Ordnung ist,
dass man das überhaupt macht und darf und welche Daten da so drüber gehen.
Nicht besonders, also eine relativ unkontrollierte Überwachungspraxis,
die da stattfindet, die sich mal jemand kümmern muss.
Ja diese Veröffentlichungen von Apple und anderen Unternehmen sind ja ganz interessant,
weil ja oft bei diesen Auskunftsersuchen ja auch die Verpflichtung mit verbunden
ist darüber nicht zu reden.
Und Unternehmen haben sich dann durch, also Apple hat das zumindest so gemacht,
so ein bisschen damit beholfen, dass sie geschrieben haben, in diesem Jahr haben
wir keine Anfrage bekommen,
sodass man halt gemerkt hat, ab wann sie Anfrage bekommen haben,
wenn sie diesen Satz nicht mehr geschrieben haben.
Genau, der Cannery, dass man regelmäßig eine Aussage veröffentlicht und dann potenziell nicht mehr.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das jetzt hier ist, ob die Anfragen auch mit einem Gag-Order
versehen waren, potenziell schon.
Aggregierte Statistiken sind auf jeden Fall spannend. Was zu erwarten wäre, ist,
dass jetzt hier auf diesen Bereich mehr Aufmerksamkeit fällt und dass sich hoffentlich
oder dass sich vermutlich ein paar Unternehmen, die es bisher allen möglichen
Kram über diese Push Notifications geballert haben,
sich jetzt mal eben Lösungen überlegen, die ähnlich wie Signal,
immer nur so ein Erwache-System, Ping sind und sich dann die Information nachgeholt wird.
Das heißt, da würde ich jetzt erwarten, dass sich hier an der Praxis noch mal einiges ändert.
Ganz grundsätzlich wurden diese zentralen Push-Notification-Services schon auch kritisiert.
Wir haben das hier, glaube ich, schon mal vor einem Jahr oder zwei diskutiert.
Da gab es dann auch Hinweise, dass es bei Android Alternativen gibt, das zu nutzen.
Aber auch nur, wenn nicht die Google-Play-Services, hast du nicht gesehen.
Aber wenn du dann irgendwie zwei, drei verschiedene Kernel kompiliert hast und
deinen Android-ROM hast du ja alles nicht gesehen, umgelötet,
dann kannst du auch einen anderen Push-Notification-Service nutzen.
Das ist also sicherlich möglich und eine Möglichkeit, die aufgrund ihrer,
also die theoretisch vorhanden ist, aber keine praktische Signifikanz in der Anwendung hat.
Insofern ist hier ein riesiges Überwachungspotenzial, um das sich jetzt hoffentlich
mal die Leute mehr kümmern werden.
Und natürlich, ja, wir auch mehr Transparenz bekommen. Die Risiken oder die
Inhalte, die dir über diese Push-Nachrichten gehen, würde ich mal vermuten,
da ist schon eine ganze Menge drüber gegangen,
was unter der Annahme verschickt wurde oder ohne besondere Vorsicht hinsichtlich
Überwachungsmöglichkeiten und Inhalten, die man vielleicht nicht darüber schicken möchte.
Es ist ja auch nicht nur eine Frage von Inhalten, sondern generell ist das natürlich
auch etwas, was man so als Fingerprinting auch ganz gut verwenden kann, weil natürlich,
wenn man eine Analyse machen kann über die Push Notifications,
insbesondere wenn man aus diesen Push Notifications herauslesen kann,
welche Programme werden denn hier überhaupt benutzt, mal ganz unabhängig davon.
Weil typische Kombinationen von Programmen sagen natürlich schon mal sehr viel darüber aus.
Wenn jetzt irgendein Telefon die ganze Zeit nur TikTok, TikTok,
YouTube und so weiter hat,
dann kannst du dir halt auch schon vorstellen, was da für eine Person dahinter
sitzt, aber wenn es halt die ganze Zeit kryptosensitive, privatsphäresensitive
Programme sind, die da zum Einsatz kommen,
dann ist das sozusagen so dieses, da hat wohl jemand was zu verbergen.
Und von daher ist das schon etwas, was auch nochmal diskutiert gehört,
wie die Regulation aussehen sollte.
Und dann natürlich, selbst wenn die Push Notifications, sagen wir mal,
die wären jetzt alle so, dass es nur Erwache Pings sind,
dann hättest du immer noch eine
Situation, wo du jetzt durch zeitliche Korrelationen gucken kannst, ne?
Ach ja, jedes Mal wenn wir da hinschicken, wenn wir an diesen,
was weiß ich, auf eine Telefonzelle registrierten Signal-Account eine Nachricht schicken,
dann geht da eine Push-Nachricht los, das machst du ein paar Mal und stellst
die Korrelation her und dann weißt du, okay, das ist das iPhone hinter diesem Account.
Da ist also eine ganze Menge zu holen, wenn man sich da alles abholt.
Dann kommen wir zu der nächsten zentralen Infrastruktur, auch da im Prinzip
die Argumentation ähnlich.
Ganz grundsätzlich wäre es möglich, das haben wir auch damals diskutiert,
dass jetzt irgendjemand sagt, wir haben ja auch noch einen Push Notification
Service, wir bauen einfach das gleiche komplett nach.
Und jetzt hättest du das Problem, dann muss die App den ja auch noch mal unterstützen,
also wenn es jetzt was Neumann Push gäbe und dann baue ich die API nach und
dann müsstet ihr an eurem Handy sagen, ja,
ich benutze Neumann Push und jede App müsste das auch unterstützen oder auf
Betriebssystemebene müsste man sagen, nee, wir nehmen nicht den Google oder
Apple Push Notification Server, sondern einen anderen.
Es hat schon, also ich kann schon verstehen, warum sich hier so ein zentralisierter
Ansatz herauskristallisiert hat.
Wenngleich es auch theoretisch man Alternativen schaffen könnte,
die dann das ganze Ökosystem unterstützen müssen und so weiter. Also ginge, aber ja.
Wird glaube ich erstmal nicht stattfinden.
Wie gesagt, bei Android gibt's das, bei Apple bin ich mal gespannt. Also, ja, mal schauen.
Erstmal kümmern wir uns jetzt darum, dass wir da ein bisschen die Überwachung
eindämmen und da mal überhaupt Transparenz schaffen.
So, nächste zentrale Infrastruktur für Mobilgeräte, auch bei uns schon in Breite
diskutiert, sind ja die App Stores und der Play Store.
Was haben die auch wieder ein bisschen zur Herleitung? wenn ihr euch jetzt irgendwie
so ein PC kauft, könnt ihr,
Executables eigentlich überall runterladen, selber kompilieren,
aus allen unterschiedlichen Quellen installieren.
Wenn ihr Microsoft benutzt oder so.
Auch auf dem Apple ist es verhältnismäßig üblich, noch auf irgendeiner Webseite
ein Programm runterzuladen und dann halt auszuführen.
Im Linux-Bereich ja schon relativ lange so, dass man eigentlich so mehrere Software-Repositories
hat, aus denen man dann installiert.
Also man sagt dann irgendwie, was weiß ich, App Update, dann wird das Repository
aktualisiert und dann sagt man App Upgrade und dann werden die aktuellen Software
aus dieser einen zentralen Quelle installiert.
Eine sehr elegante Lösung, zu der dann...
Hinzu kam, und das hat so begonnen eigentlich mit den Smartphones,
mit Apple, dass sie gesagt haben, das bauen wir auch, aber wir machen das mit Preisschild.
Wir bauen direkt eine Bezahlinfrastruktur dran und wir signieren die Software
durch, um Raubkopien zu begegnen. Das waren die zwei wichtigen Schritte für einen App Store.
Man macht ein zentrales Repository und man schafft eine Signatur-Infrastruktur,
die ermöglicht, dass man die Software, quasi die auf meinem iPhone ausgeführt
wird, die ist signiert von Apple zur Ausführung auf diesem Gerät.
Und wenn ich jetzt von meinem iPhone die App herunterkopiere auf ein anderes
iPhone, beispielsweise Tims iPhone, dann wird Tims iPhone sagen,
führe ich nicht aus, ist nicht signiert.
Das hat sicherheitsmäßig sehr, sehr große Konsequenzen.
Das macht es enorm schwieriger, Schadsoftware in Verbreitung zu bringen,
weil du immer erstmal einen Weg finden musst, dass nicht signierte Schadsoftware
ausgeführt wird und das hat einen ganz,
ganz krassen ökonomischen Effekt, nämlich dass du im Prinzip den kompletten
Markt der Raubkopien sowohl auf Android als auch auf iOS komplett trockengelegt hast.
Es gibt ja so gut wie keine nennenswerte Raubkopieaktivitäten in diesem Bereich.
Und das war für die Erstellung dieser Stores fundamental, ja.
Und man kann auch sagen, das war ein Erfolgsrezept für beide.
Also Apple hat ein Schweinegeld mit dieser Idee App Store verdient.
Und Google auch.
Primär, weil sie für diese Bereitstellung, die Dienstleistung,
es gibt einen App Store, für die Entwickler, denen natürlich Geld abnehmen.
Nimm Geld dafür ab, daran teilzunehmen. Nimm Geld dafür für jeden Verkauf.
Also im prozentualen Anteil.
Im Vergleich, wenn du jetzt, was weiß ich, eine Software...
Vor 20 Jahren eine Software für einen PC verkauft hast oder für einen Mac,
ist euch egal, für einen richtigen Computer, dann hast du potenziell,
musstest du dich selber darum kümmern,
irgendwie einen Raubkopie-Schutz zu machen, häufig durch irgendwelche Codes,
die man mit eingeben musste,
später dann gerne mal durch einen Lizenz-Server, über den du überwachst,
dass deine Lizenz auch nur jeweils einmal aktiv ist.
Du musstest alles selber machen, musstest du deine Abrechnung selber machen,
musstest du die Bereitstellung selber machen und so weiter.
Und im Mobilfunkbereich oder im Smartphone Bereich ist es eben so,
dass du da einen Dienstleistungsvertrag hast mit Apple oder Google und die sagen,
ja, pass auf, stell mal rein, der kostet 100 Euro im Jahr hier teilzunehmen, glaube ich ungefähr.
Und du kannst reinstellen, was du willst und von dem, was du da verkaufst,
nehmen wir dann halt, was ist das? 20, 30 Prozent oder so, ne?
App Store Tarife derzeit 15 Prozent bis zu der ersten Million ab dann 30.
Ah ja, ok und bei Playstore, also Tim weiß natürlich ab wann das auf einmal
30 Prozent wurde, weil die erste Million ist ja nett, dass es da noch...
Dann da wollten sie mehr von mir haben, ich weiß jetzt eigentlich nicht wofür, Lilo ist ja so...
Also irgendwas in dieser Preisspanne.
Man muss auch dazu sagen, dass die Appstores mittlerweile noch mehr machen als
nur diese Signierungen um Malware zu verhindern, mittlerweile ist ja auch.
Die machen auch das in Kasso, die machen auch die Rückgabe.
Ne auch jenseits des finanziellen, dass ja sozusagen auch die Software,
wenn ein Update gepusht wird, dann werden die Programme ja auch nochmal gescannt,
das heißt da gibt's dann halt auch richtige Malware Scanner.
Nicht nur Malware, sondern Apple durchsucht ja die Programme auch darauf hin,
ob sie irgendwelche private APIs benutzt werden etc.
Das ist nochmal ein anderes Thema. Aber grundsätzlich findet sozusagen auch
eine gewisse Dienstleistung an der Stelle statt, also für den Kunden,
weil ich möchte ja natürlich auch nicht, dass ich mir jetzt beim App Store was
runterlade und dann hab ich halt irgendein Schweinetool, Was auf irgendeinem
bösen Wege meine Daten oder noch schlimmer mein Geld abzieht.
Ist ja auch im Interesse von allen.
Genau, jetzt kann man natürlich argumentieren, das wiederum ist eine Dienstleistung
für dich und nicht unbedingt eine,
für die man jetzt dem Apple Geld abnehmen muss oder für die Apple die Software
bereitstellenden Geld abnehmen muss.
Und dann hat sich, auch wir haben hier darüber berichtet, eben vor einiger Zeit,
eine Zankerei ergeben und zwar zwischen Epic,
Epic Games, einem sehr traditionellen Computerspielehersteller,
war ein paar Jahre in der Versenkung und hat dann mit, wenn ich mich nicht täusche,
Fortnite, Players Ultimate Battleground, so einen absoluten Hit gelandet.
Ich glaube, um dieses Spiel ging es da.
Ja, Battle Royale.
Battle Royale, ja genau.
2017.
Und jetzt haben die da diesen Riesenerfolg, haben das Ding in diesen Appstore
gestellt, haben auf einmal Millionen mit diesem Spiel gemacht und stellen fest,
ey, irgendwie Google und Apple verdienen an diesem Quatsch, den wir da gemacht
haben, Millionen fürs Nix tun.
Dann haben sie gesagt, wir finden das nicht in Ordnung, was hier passiert,
wir klagen dagegen, wir bauen Bezahlmodelle an deren Appstore vorbei.
Und dann hat, wenn ich das richtig erinnere, gab's quasi so,
das ist dann eskaliert, weil dann hat Apple oder Google, ich weiß gar nicht,
wie gesagt, dann fliegt ihr halt raus, wenn ihr quasi gegen unsere...
Mit Apple fing es an. War mit Apple, ne? Ja die haben explizit ein Update rausgebracht,
wo eben dieser Sale, was halt explizit in den Nutzungsbedingungen eben untersagt
war, wo eben so ein Sale über ihren eigenen Server abgewickelt wurde.
Das wurde natürlich dann von Apple sofort gestoppt und Apple hat dann einerseits
Fortnite gesperrt und dann nach einer Weile auch den kompletten Developer Account von Epic gesperrt,
so dass sie keine Games mehr veröffentlichen konnten.
Das war auch insofern ein Problem, weil Epic Games ja nicht nur für Fortnite
bekannt ist, sondern auch dieses 3D-Environment haben, wie heißt das nochmal gleich?
Unreal Engine, die von vielen Programmen benutzt wird.
Die gehört Epic? Die haben die gekauft, oder?
Na die haben Unreal, ist von Epic.
Das ursprüngliche Unreal auch?
1998 ja.
Das war auch schon Epic? Okay irre, hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Genau, da gab es also ein Hickhack, dass jetzt sozusagen nicht auch noch Programme
rausfliegen, die diese Engine benutzen.
Das wurde irgendwie geklärt, ich hab's mir da nicht so genau angeschaut.
Und dann gab es halt einen riesigen Hackmack und natürlich auch eine Verhandlung
vor Gericht, wo Apple eigentlich weitgehend recht bekommen hat.
Jetzt sind sie aber auch nochmal gegen Google vorgegangen und jetzt ist es sich
da unter anderem ausgegangen.
Dann sind sie an eine andere Jury geraten.
Also langer, langer wie man sich das vorstellen kann Prozess um Millionen mit vielen Punkten.
Ich glaube in diesem Fall hat Epic in.
Vier Punkten recht bekommen. Also Google wurde vorgeworfen,
dass sie den Play Store illegal an ein Bezahlsystem binden, sodass beides benutzt werden muss.
Wir sind also hier wieder in
einer Diskussion über marktbeherrschende Stellung und diese auszunutzen.
Und jetzt könnte natürlich Google sagen, wir haben ein Bezahlsystem,
aber du musst nicht unbedingt das vom App Store nutzen, ja, und da wird also
jetzt argumentiert und pipapo.
Und de facto ist, glaube ich, relativ klar, dass Epic nicht in der Lage ist,
sein Geschäftsmodell auf dieser Plattform zu verfolgen,
ohne eben signifikante, potenziell etwas zu hohe Gebühren an Google zu entrichten.
Und jetzt hat die Jury entschieden, dass diese Praxis des Playstores ein illegales Monopol ist,
unter dem eben die marktbeherrschende Stellung ausgenutzt wird,
um exorbitante Gebühren zu verlangen,
den Wettbewerb zu ersticken und die Innovation einzuschränken.
Ja, und da kommen, das haben die jetzt geurteilt und das kann relativ üble...
Konsequenzen für Google und Apple haben, wenn sich das jetzt so durchsetzt.
Weil dann müssen Apple und Google den Würgegriff lösen und andere App-Stores zulassen,
um diese Geschäftspraxis, die
sie da haben, einer Konkurrenz und einer Innovation zugänglich zu machen.
Ja, das ist das ist noch nicht so ganz klar, weil also abgesehen davon,
dass Google natürlich in Berufung gehen wird und die Sache von daher noch lange
nicht abgeschlossen ist.
Deswegen habe ich ja gesagt, dass wir das ja kollektiv verwenden.
Jaja, ist schon klar. Und was auch noch dazu kommt, es ist ja auch noch nicht
klar, was jetzt eigentlich die Konsequenz daraus ist.
Also die Jury hat entschieden, der Richter noch nicht. Genau.
Aber jetzt spielen wir es mal durch. Also ich würde, wenn ich jetzt Epic wäre,
würde ich sagen, so Google, dann lass mal gucken, dass wir uns hier noch außergerichtlich einigen.
Aber es sieht schon relativ schwierig aus, weil ich glaube, wenn die Juryentscheidung
da ist, dann muss jetzt die Richterin oder der Richter auch ein Urteil fällen
und das wird Google jetzt so schnell nicht mehr los, dieses Problem.
Das hätten sie früher loswerden können, wenn sie sich mit Epic irgendwie finanziell geeinigt hätten.
Das ist nicht passiert. Mit anderen ist ihnen das übrigens gelungen.
Also die haben, glaube ich, mit Tinder und Spotify irgendwelche Einigungen.
Zum Beispiel Spotify hat Anfang des Jahres einen Deal mit Google bekommen,
dass Google auf einen Teil der Einnahmen verzichtet.
In dem Fall glaube ich noch schlimmer, weil es ja sicherlich von Google auch
irgendeinen Musikdienst gibt, genauso wie von Apple.
Das heißt, da haben sie noch schwierigere Konstellationen, weil sie auch nochmal
mit dem Dienst Spotify in direkter Konkurrenz stehen.
Technisch könnte die, also das Ding zu Ende durchgespielt hieße,
Google muss andere App-Stores erlauben und darf denen keine Steine in den Weg
werfen und dann wäre das potenziell auch für Apple der Fall.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob das unbedingt im Sinne der Nutzerinnen ist,
wenn es jetzt auf einmal mehrere Stores gibt und du weißt nicht mehr,
wo du gekauft hast und hast ja alles nicht gesehen,
aber es könnte natürlich auch, also das Erste, was mir da einfiele,
was für die Nutzerinnen positiv sein könnte, wäre eine Anbieterin, die es dir ermöglicht,
den Zugangsrecht einer App zu kaufen und wenn du es da gekauft hast,
kannst du es auf Android und iOS benutzen.
Ja, also es ist schwierig zu klären diese Frage.
Ich denke, dass da alle Seiten irgendwo einen Punkt haben. Man will natürlich
Businessmodelle haben,
die flexiblere Einnahmen ermöglichen und kommst halt immer genau dann in Probleme
oder unter anderem auch dann in Probleme, wenn eben Plattformbetreiber selber
auch Dienstanbieter sind, wie das Musikbeispiel zeigt.
Andererseits ist natürlich diese Grundhaltung von Epic mit ihr habt irgendwie
uns gar nichts zu sagen und nur unsere Programme sind relevant und eure Plattformen,
da scheißen wir doch drauf.
Ist natürlich auch nur so begrenzt haltbar. Weil das ist ja jetzt nicht so,
dass jetzt kein Aufwand getrieben wird, diese Plattformen überhaupt am Laufen
zu erhalten, erfolgreich zu machen und auch sicher zu gestalten.
Das ist ja, ich glaube, das steht ja auch außer Frage. Also das muss man nochmal,
weil das häufig falsch verstanden wird, muss man das natürlich nochmal spezifisch
trennen. Natürlich ist das mit Aufwand verbunden.
Natürlich ist das eine Dienstleistung, für die auch jede Konkurrenz Geld nehmen würde.
Aber in dem Moment, wo du, und ich hatte das hier schon mal besprochen,
nur weil du eine marktbeherrschende Stellung hast,
ist es noch nicht falsch, wenn du dann aber dabei erwischt wirst,
diese marktbeherrschende Stellung auszunutzen, um Konkurrenz zu verhindern und
potenziell, sagen wir mal ein bisschen frech, hohe Preise zu verlangen,
dann bekommst du halt Antitrust-Verfahren.
Und das ist hier passiert.
Und bei einer prozentualen Preisgestaltung kann man schon argumentieren,
dass das eigentlich egal an welcher Stelle du da bist, ob du jetzt einer von
den Indie Developers bist, die 15% abgeben müssen.
Oder einer von den ganz großen Developern, die 30% abgeben müssen,
kann man immer sagen, das ist schon nicht knapp.
Ja, also, äh, ja. Und es wäre ja nicht so, wenn der App Store eine eigene Dienstleistung wäre.
Jetzt kommt natürlich auch der Punkt, der ist ja vorinstalliert auf einem Telefon.
Man kann jetzt die Argumentation vortragen, dass Apple und Google einerseits
Telefone verkaufen, sehr schön,
Andererseits einen App Store betreiben, diese beiden aber in eine unheilige
Allianz bringen und quasi bei der Telefonsoftware sicherstellen,
dass der App Store drin ist und umgekehrt und dass da natürlich zwei marktbeherrschende
Stellungen übel kombiniert werden zum Nachteil aller anderen.
Und ich glaube, das Argument ist vertretbar.
Das hätte ich, glaube ich, auch so entschieden.
Ich persönlich habe aus meiner Konsumentensicht keinen dringenden Bedarf an
einem weiteren App-Store.
Bin eigentlich ganz zufrieden mit der Architektur, wie sie jetzt ist,
aber finde es auch schon, sag ich mal,
sinnvoll, dass da mal jemand guckt, wenn an egal welcher App irgendjemand auf
mein Handy bringt, Und da mindestens 15% der Einnahme an Apple gehen,
kann ich schon verstehen, dass man da mal argumentieren kann,
dass das vielleicht ein bisschen viel ist.
Ja und dass das nicht in einem direkten Verhältnis zu dem Aufwand steht, denn mit, ja.
15% finde ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so problematisch, weil, wenn man...
Keine andere Ausgabe wird 15% sein von denen.
Von wem wird 15% keine Ausgabe?
Sag mal du bist ein Spieleentwicklungsstudio.
Und du hast gewisse Kosten.
Du kaufst vielleicht irgendwelche Softwarelizenzen, damit deine Entwickler arbeiten
können und je mehr Entwickler du hast, desto bessere Produkte kannst du machen
und so weiter und so fort.
Und irgendwann bist du an dem Punkt, dass du endlich Glück hast und dein Produkt skaliert.
Was in der IT das eine Ding ist oder im Softwarehandel das eine Ding ist.
Massenhaft verkaufen, um mehr Geld zu verdienen. Und dann wird jede einzelne
Ausgabe, die du hast, prozentual an deinem Jahresumsatz sinken.
Das ist die gesamte Idee.
Und hier ist jetzt jemand und sagt, ach übrigens, auf 15 Prozent kannst du vollständig verzichten.
Für immer. Und wenn du mehr verkaufst, wird auch dieser Anteil nicht geringer,
dann ist es garantiert die höchste und schlimmste und schwerste Ausgabe,
die die in ihrer Bilanz haben.
Naja, also ich meine wenn du mal anschaust welchen Aufwand du sonst hättest
um die Sicherheit deines Produktes, den Vertrieb, dann diese Raubkopie,
Verhinderungsmaßnahmen,
Kreditkarten, Gebühren zum Beispiel, die auch nicht erheblich sind,
Gebühren für Erstattung, das ganze Handling, Installation, Downloadserver,
also dass das jetzt ein Nullbetrag ist, das kann man nun auch nicht behaupten.
Ne weiß ich, dass du das nicht gesagt hast, aber das ist nur eine generelle
Aufstellung wie man das zu bewerten hat.
Also ich sehe schon, dass die Appstores eine nennenswerte Dienstleistung erbringen,
nicht nur für die Kunden, auch für die Kunden, aber auch für die Entwickler,
weil dadurch natürlich auch sehr vieles sehr viel einfacher ist.
Vertrieb in allen Ländern, Promotion über den App Store etc.
Also es gibt viel zu kritisieren da dran, aber ich würde nicht behaupten,
dass jetzt ein Schnitt von 15 Prozent an sich ein Problem ist.
Also das ist in meinen Augen eine Größenordnung, mit der man schon argumentieren
kann und die du halt einfach in deinen Preis einfach mit einrechnen.
Wie argumentierst du, dass das dann plötzlich bei mehr App-Verkaufen 30 Prozent wird?
Ja gut, das sind so diese Blockbuster, die halt so richtig viel Kohle verdienen.
Das war ja der ursprüngliche Betrag. Also am Anfang waren es ja 30 Prozent.
Das ist dann vor zwei Jahren oder so auf 15 Prozent runtergegangen,
eben für Unternehmen, die erstmal weniger verdienen.
Das heißt im Prinzip gehen sie nach wie vor mit ihrem 70-30 Anteil und auch
den kann man unter diesen genannten Argumenten vielleicht noch argumentieren,
vielleicht mag sich das auch mittlerweile verschoben haben, vielleicht kann
man den auch mal senken oder so,
aber eigentlich ist das ja ein sehr sozialistischer Ansatz den ich mir vorgestellt habe.
Naja ich meine Steuern sind halt einfach, fangen halt niedriger an und du hast
dann so eine Progression.
So wer viel verdient muss auch viel abgeben, bestimmte Sachen skalieren ja auch,
also so Facebook Updates und so weiter dürften wahrscheinlich auch einen Großteil
der Downloadkosten verursachen.
Während irgendeine Zippel App, die dein Time-Tracking macht,
die 20.000 mal runtergeladen wird und alle 3 Jahre mal Update hat,
die wirft halt keine Kosten auf, aber so Apps, die sich permanent updaten.
Petabytes wahrscheinlich übertragen werden für jedes Update,
die machen ja auch Kosten.
Ich will das jetzt nicht rechtfertigen oder so ich sag nur es ist nachvollziehbar,
dass das hier auch eine Dienstleistung und Sicherstellung des gesamten Ökosystems
stattfindet und darum wollte ich jetzt eigentlich hinaus, Epic hat sich halt,
dieser Tim Sweeney, der CEO,
der ist halt auch nicht ganz sauber, weil der halt so in diesem Grundansatz
ist mit ihr habt da eigentlich überhaupt nichts zu verdienen,
wir sind die einzigen, die hier Value geben und ohne unsere Apps wäre ja euer
ganzer scheiß Appstore gar nichts.
Und davon halte ich halt auch nicht sehr viel.
Ich hab auch gerade mal geguckt, es läuft ja gerade die Abstimmung The Worst
Person in Tech 2023, ich weiß nicht ob du das gesehen hast,
das läuft ja jedes Jahr, da wird dann irgendwie online abgestimmt,
wer denn jetzt sozusagen die schlimmste Person ist.
Als we speak befinden wir uns gerade im Achtelfinale,
da sind jetzt, also es ist immer so ein Two-Person-Shootout,
also man hat halt mit 32 Leuten angefangen und dann muss man sich immer zwischen
zwei entscheiden wer ist denn jetzt schlimmer.
Wir sind also zwei Runden durch und derzeit sind weitergekommen Elon Musk,
der sich in der nächsten Runde gegen Larry Ellison wahrscheinlich durchsetzen wird.
Dann Peter Thiel denke ich mal hat gute Chancen gegen Paul Malacchi,
das ist dieser Oculus VR Gründer sich durchzusetzen.
Dann David Zaslav, der ist mir ja komplett neu, das ist der CEO von Warner Brothers,
der muss gegen Jeff Bezos antreten, ich glaube da ist Bezos auch noch ganz vorne.
Und spannend wird's im Shootout zwischen Sam Bankman-Fried und Sam Altman gegeneinander.
Also da bin ich sehr gespannt, ob Sam Bankman-Fried, der alte Crypto-Bro,
noch genug Stamina nach seiner Verurteilung hat, sich gegen Sam Altman durchzusetzen,
was Worst-Person-In-Tech betrifft.
Aber von Tim Sweeney ist hier nix zu lesen. Letztes Jahr war der bestimmt noch
dabei. Ich weiß es nicht, ich muss nochmal nachgucken.
Achso, ich wollte gerade... also...
Entscheidende Sache ist, also ich würde sagen, sicherlich handelt es sich bei
den Appstore-Gebühren nicht um ein karitatives Angebot.
Und zumindest hier wurde jetzt eine Jury davon überzeugt, dass es sich sogar
um das Ausnutzen oder um eine Ausnutzung einer marktbeherrschenden Stellung handelt.
Und ich denke, dieses Argument ist nicht allzu schwer zu führen.
Es gibt eine Reihe an Ja-Abers zu den Ja-Abers gehört einerseits,
sie schützen, sie schaffen da wirklich ein Ökosystem.
Sie haben ja auch diese Geräte überhaupt erstmal in unsere Taschen verkauft.
Und ganz klar ist diese Dienstleistung nicht nichts wert.
Und das sagt auch niemand. Also das muss ich nochmal wiederholen.
Niemand sagt, dass diese Dienstleistung kostenlos zur Verfügung gestellt werden müsste,
sondern es wird gesagt, dadurch, dass es für diese Dienstleistung keine Konkurrenz
gibt und die Gebühren potenziell leicht unbotmäßig sind, muss hier was passieren.
Und diese Argumentation kann ich durchaus zumindest mal nachvollziehen.
Wenngleich, ich jetzt sagen würde, ich persönlich vermisse nichts und ich bin happy,
wenn ich, also vermutlich wird es eine Konkurrenzplattform an Appstores schwer
haben, mich davon zu überzeugen, sie überhaupt nutzen zu wollen.
Aber hier geht es eben auch um eine rechtliche Auseinandersetzung,
was Markt- und Wettbewerbsrechte angeht und das ist für mich relativ naheliegend,
dass sie da verlieren werden.
So, ja, genau, haben wir jetzt gesehen. Also das Urteil der Jury ist ja jetzt da, ne.
Frage ist, was die Richter daraus machen.
Aber wir haben ja diese Diskussion, dass sie Sideloading erlauben müssen,
führen sie schon länger und bereiten sich ja auch langsam darauf vor.
Und dann wird die Konsequenz sein, ja, wenn man jetzt mal der Lehre des Wettbewerbs folgt,
dann wird die Konsequenz sein, dass es potenziell alternative App Stores geben
wird, die eventuell bessere,
irgendwie bessere Deals oder Innovationen für die Nutzerinnen und Nutzer bieten,
dann einen geringen Marktanteil damit erlangen und dann wird Apple gezwungen
sein, diese Innovationen auch mitzugehen.
Sei es ein faireres oder, sagen wir mal, kostenverbundeneres Pricing oder sei
es irgendwelche besonderen Vorteile für die Nutzerinnen und Nutzer.
Und die Lehre des Wettbewerbs wäre dann eben, dass hier durch eine Verbesserung
im Interesse der Marktteilnehmer in der Breite dieses potenziellen Marktes erfolgt.
So, dann schauen wir ein bisschen auf die Anstrengungen der EU.
Ja, da gibt es im Prinzip jetzt zwei Sachen.
Einmal den AI-Act, der da in der Schmiede ist und kurz vorm Ziel gewissermaßen,
den werden wir dann nochmal in späteren Folgen genauer behandeln und außerdem
gibt es den European Health Data Space.
Zu beiden will ich eigentlich nur mal ein kurzes Update machen.
Beim AI-Act ist jetzt quasi das Verbot der automatisierten Gesichtserkennung raus.
Beziehungsweise also nicht das grundsätzliche Verbot raus, es gibt halt Einschränkungen
oder es gibt jetzt Bedingungen unter denen diese Echtzeitüberwachung,
biometrische Echtzeitüberwachung stattfinden kann, das bedeutet aber auch,
es gibt jetzt eine Rechtsgrundlage das zu tun, ja.
Und das ist natürlich relativ schlecht, weil wir kennen das,
sobald einmal solche Rechtsgrundlagen da sind, werden sie weiter ausgehöhlt.
Das ist im Prinzip das Gleiche wie bei der Chat-Kontrolle.
Ja, eigentlich ist es gerade verboten.
Jetzt gibt es Bedingungen, unter denen es erlaubt wird. Dann werden diese Bedingungen
vollständig ausgeschöpft und dann werden sie abgemindert.
Und das ist sicherlich etwas ärgerlich.
Was sehr spannend ist, sind auch die Ausnahmen des AI-Acts, wo zum Beispiel drin steht,
diese Verordnung gilt nicht für KI-Systeme, die ausschließlich für militärische
Zwecke entwickelt oder verwendet werden. Also alles, was wir an Grundrechten usw.
Und irgendwelchen Safeguards haben, für militärische Zwecke,
ist schon mal raus. Und von vielen Pflichten sind dann auch Autos und autonome
Flugzeuge befreit, zumindest im aktuellen Entwurf der Kommission.
Das heißt, da wird jetzt wieder eine Reihe an Ausnahmen gemacht und ich denke,
biometrische Massenüberwachung des öffentlichen Raumes ist schon wirklich ein
irrer, fundamentaler Einschnitt.
Und diese biometrische Massenüberwachung ist sehr nah, denn die Datenbanken
dafür haben die Staaten ja schon ungefähr vor einem Jahrzehnt angefangen zu bauen.
Ich glaube, ich hatte auch hier im Podcast das besprochen, die Verpflichtung so zum...
Biometrischen Foto in Ausweis und Pass ist ungefähr zehn Jahre alt oder über zehn Jahre alt.
Damit haben wir jetzt einmal die Bevölkerung durch, weil ein Personalausweis
hat nur zehn Jahre Gültigkeit.
Also seitdem es das gibt, haben alle jetzt mal ein biometrisches Bild abgegeben.
Das heißt, es gibt diese Datenbank. Wir haben auch hier schon darüber besprochen,
es war ungefähr vor ein oder zwei Jahren, wo der Zugriff auf diese zentralen
biometrischen Datenbanken einfacher möglich werden soll.
Und jetzt Das wäre der Punkt, dass die mit einer Gesichtserkennung verbunden
werden und dann hast du relativ zeitnah überall, wo eine öffentliche Kamera ist,
auch diese Gesichtserkennung drauf und das klingt jetzt irgendwie alles noch
ganz lustig, bedeutet aber am Ende,
das Tracking, über das wir uns im Internet zu Recht beschweren durch diese Werbeanbieter,
die unser Verhalten analysieren und so weiter.
Genau dieses Tracking, was wir im Internet so schlecht finden,
wäre dann im öffentlichen Raum anhand unseres Gesichtes der Fall.
Und das ist sicherlich keine positive Entwicklung.
Gleichzeitig werden beim AI-Act natürlich noch Themen und Kritikpunkte besprochen,
dass hier jetzt eine neue Technologie mit sehr hohen Potenzialen als Bedrohung wahrgenommen wird.
Es wird ja auch eine ganze Menge diskutiert, deswegen konzentrieren wir uns
jetzt heute mal nur auf diese biometrische Massenüberwachung,
die sicherlich nicht besonders wünschenswert ist.
Absolut überhaupt nicht wünschenswert, weil das ist halt auch wieder so eine
klassische Technologie, wenn man das erst mal da hat, dann wird es sehr schwierig,
das wieder loszuwerden.
Also das ist ja ein Desaster, die Vollzeiterfassung des öffentlichen Raumes,
mit jede Person identifiziert.
Schlimm. Da hätte man mal eine
Chance gehabt, da hätte man mal einer Risikotechnologie begegnen können.
Ja und das ist aber dann immer so, dass irgendeiner wahrscheinlich aus Polizeikreisen,
Ermittlungskreisen heraus, nee das könnte man ja noch für irgendwas gebrauchen
und bloß nicht verbieten, das ist ganz schlimm und dann hast du den Scheiß.
Dann gibt es eine, auch das würden wir noch mal in einer späteren Folge genauer diskutieren,
die elektronische Patientenakte und das elektronische Rezept, ja,
ist jetzt auf dem Weg, ja, Bundestag hat es auf den Weg gebracht und ganz grundsätzlich
ist das, haben wir ja hier auch schon ausführlich diskutiert, keine,
Das Gesundheitssystem zu digitalisieren, ist sicherlich keine allgemein schlechte Idee.
Man muss sich aber darüber im Auge, oder man muss sich darüber bewusst sein,
dass es hier um eine kritische Infrastruktur handelt, mit hochsensiblen Daten.
Und das ist natürlich dort, man einfach mal vielleicht die, diesen Reichtum
an Wissen über IT-Sicherheit und Datenschutz sinnvoll zur Anwendung bringen kann.
Ja, Privacy by Design Konzepte, Kryptografie, geschützte Systeme.
Wir haben ja für alle Herausforderungen, die es da gibt, Möglichkeiten,
die technisch zu erfüllen.
Die Corona-Warn-App wäre hier ein Beispiel,
wo für ein Problem eine zielgerichtete Privacy-Preserving-Lösung gefunden und
ausgerollt wurde und nicht das Kind mit dem Bade ausgekippt wurde.
Insofern sind natürlich jetzt diejenigen, die diesen Prozess kritisch begleiten
in einer schwierigen Position, dass sie einerseits sagen müssen,
ja ja, macht das schon, ist in Ordnung, aber dann lasst es doch bitte wenigstens
versuchen, das irgendwie ordentlich zu machen.
Und das scheint unter anderem auch durch die Eile von Karl Lauterbach,
der das jetzt schnell hinter sich bringen will, durchaus in Frage gestellt, dass das hier passiert.
Insofern gibt es da einen offenen Brief, dem sich auch der Chaos Computer Club
angeschlossen hat, wo ein paar
Prüfsteine zur Digitalisierung des Gesundheitswesens formuliert werden.
Ihr werdet euch erinnern, das mit den Prüfsteinen haben wir auch damals bei
der Corona-Warn-App gemacht.
Gesellschaftliche Prüfsteine. Es muss quasi individuell freigegeben werden.
Welche Gesundheitsdaten weitergegeben werden müssen verschattet werden,
also quasi pseudonymisiert oder anonymisiert.
Und diese Kraft muss oder diese
Entscheidungshoheit muss natürlich bei den Nutzerinnen und Nutzern sein.
Es muss der Interessenskonflikt oder die Interessenskonflikte abgewogen werden.
Wer darauf zugreift und diese Sachen betreibt.
Also welche Betriebsärztin haben auf was Zugriff, was ist ein privater Arzt und so weiter.
Am Ende soll das alles das Allgemeinwohl fördern und nicht unbedingt die Interessen
der zentralisierten Betreiber solcher Infrastrukturen.
Natürlich muss medizinische Fachexpertise weiter eingebunden werden,
sodass was auch immer dort geschaffen wird, eben medizinischen Ideen gehorcht.
Wenn hier Forschung stattfinden soll, natürlich auch die Patientinnen eingebunden
werden und dass sie sinnvoll darüber aufgeklärt werden.
Dann gibt es noch prozessuale Anforderungen, dass neutrale Dritte in Konzeption
und technischer Umsetzung beteiligt werden.
Ja, dass also Leute da sind, die nicht die Dollarzeichen am anderen Ende sehen.
Oder ihre spezifischen Interessen, beispielsweise an der Forschung.
Das ist ja ein absolut berechtigtes, tolles Interesse.
Aber es gibt eben noch andere in unserer Gesellschaft, sodass hier eben auch Patientinnen,
Wissenschaft, Zivilgesellschaft und so weiter mit eingebunden werden,
um hier auch eine Wahrung der Interessen.
Sicherzustellen. Und technisch natürlich, dass der Stand der Technik mit zeitgemäßen
Sicherheitsparadigmen umgesetzt wird.
Das haben wir bisher nicht unbedingt so gesehen, dass ein hohes Niveau von Privatsphäre
und IT-Sicherheit grundlegend implementiert und gewahrt wird und dass natürlich
auch eine technische Transparenz hergestellt wird und die Systeme prüfbar sind.
Dass wir also hier sagen, wir wollen verhindern,
dass da ein eingeschränkter Interessenskreis etwas baut, das potenziell die
ein oder andere Abwägung im Bereich der IT-Sicherheit, des Datenschutzes und
der Risikovermeidung vornimmt,
um den eigenen Geschäftsansatz vielleicht ein bisschen zu erleichtern.
Das sollte natürlich vermieden werden.
Ich denke, auch hier werden wir also noch viel darüber diskutieren.
Im Moment finde ich es sehr wichtig zu zeigen oder sich dem auch entgegenzustellen.
Wir haben das ja schon öfter auf irgendwelchen Diskussionen gehört,
wo dann irgendwelche Gematikleute sagen, ihr tötet Menschen,
wenn ihr nicht sofort alle Daten freigebt.
Also von so einem Niveau der Diskussion muss man runterkommen.
Und besonders positiv ist das natürlich hier, Ich freue mich hier über diesen
konstruktiven Ansatz zu sagen, ja natürlich gibt es hier irre Potenziale.
Klar, lasst uns die bergen, aber lasst uns die mal bitte im Interesse der Patientinnen
und Patienten bergen und nehmt doch mal bitte den Rat derer,
die sich mit IT auskennen, durchaus hier auch mit zur Kenntnis.
Finde ich völlig in Ordnung.
Schwierig mit dem zur Kenntnis nehmen von Rat.
Am besten soll er umgesetzt werden ja.
Achja.
Tim wie geht es eigentlich deinen Bitcoins?
Ich habe keine mehr.
Hast du bei Binance alle an irgendwelche anderen Kriminellen verkauft oder was hast du gemacht?
Bei Binance war ich nie und habe da nicht eine einzige Transaktion gemacht.
Mein ganzes Bitcoin Engagement ist jetzt mittlerweile schon lange her und ich
wollte das alles loswerden. wenn ich damit nichts mehr zu tun haben wollte.
Das gilt natürlich nicht unbedingt für alle Leute, hab ich gemerkt.
Manche sind ja dann immer noch in Goldgräberstimmung,
aber wenn man sich mal so anschaut, was eigentlich so im Cryptomarkt gerade
so läuft oder was eigentlich seit zwei Jahren nochmal verstärkt läuft und eigentlich
seit Anfang an oder zumindest in den letzten fünf Jahren,
Nachdem das alles sich so unfassbar kommerzialisiert hat, eingesetzt hat.
Ich sag nur web3isgoinggreat.com nach wie vor so ein Blog, wenn man das mal
so durchrauschen lässt, das ist wirklich fantastisch.
Also wirklich jeden Tag werden irgendwelche Leute entweder um Millionen betrogen
oder Unternehmen müssen ihren Betrieb einstellen, weil all ihre ganzen Versprechen
mit NFTs und was nicht alles, alles nicht mehr haltbar war.
Keine Rücklagen da waren, weil sie die ganze Kohle, die sie da kryptomäßig eingenommen
haben, schon wieder dreimal ausgegeben haben und so weiter und so fort.
Einer derjenigen, der bis... also wir hatten ja noch diesen großen Sam Bankman-Fried-Skandal,
den wir hier angesprochen haben.
Also die Bude hat ja nun wirklich alles falsch gemacht und...
Sam Bengrin Friedlich, ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir das überhaupt berichtet,
ist ja jetzt auch eingeknastet und verurteilt worden,
also der ist jetzt wirklich der Hauptschuldige und ist in allen Anklagepunkten
auch für schuldig befunden worden und das wird dauern bis der aus dem Knast rauskommt.
Urteil ist aber noch, also genau, ähnlich wie in dem Google-Verfahren,
das Urteil der Geschworenen ist da, aber noch nicht das Strafmaß,
das die Richterin dann bestimmt oder der Richter.
Okay gut, aber das wird nicht gut enden. Also ich weiß es jetzt gerade nicht,
muss ich zugeben, das habe ich nicht verfolgt.
Ganz interessant ist auf jeden Fall, was jetzt um Binance sich abspielt.
Also wenn man jetzt so sagt, so ja Kryptomarkt, alles ganz schlimm,
alles ganz furchtbar, dann kommen dann die Leute und sagen, wieso hier?
Line is going up, also Preise steigen doch wieder, ist doch alles total super.
Naja, das Ding ist, die ganzen Dynamiken in diesem Markt, der eigentlich nur
von Spekulationen getrieben ist,
das hat halt nichts mit wirklichen Märkten zu tun, sondern es gibt viele nachgewiesene
Methoden, wie solche Kurssteigerungen auch herbeigeführt werden können und so
war das bisher auch immer.
Und die ganzen Unternehmen allerdings, die haben halt derzeit viel mit den Gerichten zu tun.
Also das ist sozusagen das Problem und einer nach dem anderen von diesen ganzen
Tech-Bros dieser Szene werden halt jetzt vor Gericht geführt.
Und jetzt hat es zuletzt den CEO von einer der größten Crypto-Trading-Unternehmen
getroffen, nämlich Binance.
Changpeng Cao, Kanadier, der musste also zugeben, dass sein Unternehmen unter
seiner Führung so allerlei illegale Aktivitäten durchgeführt hat bzw.
Illegale Aktivitäten nicht verhindert hat, so wie es die Bankenregulierung in den USA vorsieht.
Die haben sich halt immer auf Wir sind ja Offshore, wir sind ja nirgendwo,
Kryptowelt ist ja alles.
Was haben wir mit Regulierungsbehörden zu tun? Ja nur weil unsere Computer auf
Land stehen, rein von Gedanken her, befinden wir uns im Orbit oder auf hoher
See und haben mit euren Regulationen nichts zu tun.
Nur, dass die Gerichte das jetzt ganz anders sehen überraschenderweise.
Und Bidens eben nachgewiesen haben,
dass sie eben sich nicht an Antigeldwäschemaßnahmen beteiligt haben und sich
auch generell einfach mit dem, was sie tun, sich nicht korrekt registriert haben.
Also sich zum Beispiel so als Money Transfer Agent eintragen zu lassen.
Also wenn du jetzt hier sowas wie Western Union, womit du deine Kohle durch
die Welt schicken kannst, die sind natürlich auch als Money Transfer Agent registriert.
Es gibt noch eine ähnliche Regelung auch im europäischen Gesetz.
Dann hast du halt diverse Auflagen, musst halt dokumentieren,
damit eben verhindert werden kann, dass sanktionierte Orte zum Beispiel keine Kohle erhalten.
Also du kannst jetzt nicht einfach
Millionen nach Russland transferieren heutzutage, weil du es geil findest.
Und wir wissen ja alle, dass es in der Kryptowelt eigentlich relativ einfach
ist, weil es eben schon eine Möglichkeit gibt, zumindest eingeschränkt hier,
wenn nicht anonym, dann doch zumindest pseudonym unterwegs zu sein,
solange du dich innerhalb der Kryptowelt befindest.
Aber irgendwo brauchst du ja dann auch mal richtiges Geld, weil Kryptogeld bezahlt
ja nix, es ist ja eigentlich nur so ein Transfergeld und deswegen sind halt
solche Wechselbuden wie Binance sehr interessant,
weil dort quasi aus dem Spekulationsgut Kryptobits echtes Geld wird.
Und wenn dann halt die Unternehmen sagen, uns ist doch egal,
wer hier seine Kohle in Euro oder Dollar tauscht, was haben wir mit Gesetzen zu tun,
dann werden die Aufsichtsbehörden dann doch mittlerweile sehr hellhörig und
das sind sie hier eben geworden.
Der Changpeng Zhao muss sich jetzt zurücktreten als CEO und eine Strafe von
nicht weniger als 4,3 Milliarden US-Dollar zahlen, also eher.
Der wurde glaube ich mal auf 17 geschätzt, also harter Schlag.
Macht euch keine Sorgen, also um ihn.
Nee, der kann auf jeden Fall noch sein Essen bezahlen.
Von daher fragt man sich warum die Strafe nicht auch höher ausgefallen ist,
aber trotzdem ist es ja nicht nichts.
Dem Unternehmen wurden also Transaktionen, Geldtransaktionen nach Iran, Kuba, Syrien,
Ukraine, in die von Russland besetzten Gebiete nachgewiesen und das ging halt
alles gar nicht und das führte dann zu dieser Strafe.
Und auch das Unternehmen wurde also jetzt mit entsprechenden Restriktionen auferlegt,
die es so vorher noch nicht hatte.
Und das ist nicht nix. So ein Rechtsexperte hat das als eine 365 Tage im Jahr
Finanzkoloskopie durchgeführt. Weißt du was eine Koloskopie ist?
Ja. Möchtest du das erklären, Tim?
Das ist eine Darmspiegelung. Ich finde diesen Begriff sehr schön in diesem Zusammenhang
mit der Finanzkoloskopie.
Also mit anderen Worten, wer davon ausgegangen ist, man könnte auf Binance jenseits
von Aufsichtsbehörden in irgendeiner Form finanzielle Geldtransaktionen durchführen. No more.
Also ab jetzt müssen Sie da haarklein alles berichten, was darüber abläuft.
Und nicht nur das, es wird auch in den Transaktionen der letzten fünf Jahre,
also bis 2018 rückwirkend, nachgeblättert.
Ob denn da irgendetwas ist, was nochmal besonders auffällig geworden ist.
Das heißt da wird wahrscheinlich nicht jede Transaktion angeschaut,
aber da werden sie halt irgendwie ihre Analyseskripte über die Datenbank laufen
lassen und mal gucken ob denen da irgendwas besonderes auffällt.
Binance redet sich das natürlich als neue Chance schön.
Ja so nach dem Motto, wir begrüßen das und das ist ja jetzt unser Einstieg in
den Mainstream und wenn wir jetzt so konform sind und so, dann können ja auch alle mitmachen und so.
Aber ich hab so eher das Gefühl es handelt sich hier um eine Nutzerschaft,
die bisher von diesem Dienstleister angezogen war,
die vielleicht unter diesen neuen Bedingungen dann ihre Transaktionen dort nicht
mehr so gerne durchführt und wie das dann bei dem Unternehmen aussieht werden wir dann sehen.
Also schön finde ich ja vor allem auch, wenn man sich jetzt überlegt,
wie die mal angetreten sind mit ihren Cryptocoins.
Hier Zentralbank und so, wo war alles nicht und wer macht da alles irgendwie
parallel und so und hier lasst euch von Keimen und nicht überwachen und so.
Und jetzt haben sie da so einen Live-Rüssel in so eine Echtzeit-Kolonoskopie.
Ist schon ganz gut.
Läuft nicht immer so gut.
So, dann haben wir, ich glaube, noch ein bisschen kleine KI-Scherze.
Also wir erinnern uns, Elon Musk ist ja mit seiner eigenen KI angetreten,
weil, also der Mann ist ja von einer großen Sorge geprägt und das ist Wokeness, das ist Woke-Virus.
Das erinnert, da haben wir glaube ich auch hier mal drüber gelacht,
da hatte irgendwie eines seiner Kinder ist woke und das kann nur von Twitter
gekommen sein, deswegen hat er Twitter gekauft, um dem irgendwie entgegen zu treten.
Und die Universitäten, weil die ja neomarxistischen Einfluss.
So war es genau, neomarxistischer Einfluss der Universitäten und der Kind ist
dann auf Twitter trans geworden oder was auch immer ihn da beschäftigt und jetzt
ballert er erstmal Twitter voll mit seinen antisemitischen Ideen ja und hat dann gesagt,
wir müssen jetzt hier den Grog machen, das ist ja seine KI,
die Ex-AI, die nicht so woke wie Chachipiti sein soll, um da eben gegen zu feuern.
Und jetzt gibt es die ersten Leute, die dann Grog fragen, jo,
wie ist das denn eigentlich hier mit den Juden?
Regieren die denn die Welt? Und dann sagt Grog, nein, du bist hier einer einer
der ältesten Verschwörungstheorien überhaupt aufgelaufen.
Die Wahrheit ist, das gibt es nicht. Und da ist eine schwere unterdrückte Minderheit.
Und jetzt beschweren sich die Leute, dass Grog irgendwie woke Garbage ist.
Finde ich sehr schön. Man weiß eben bei diesen KIs nie, was sie lernen und versucht
sie dann entsprechend zu füttern.
Währenddessen, während Elon Musks Frankenstein jetzt auf einmal entgegen aller
Hoffnung nicht auf jede noch so dämliche Verschwörungstheorie setzt.
Agiert Axel Springer strategisch und ist jetzt eine Partnerschaft mit Chat-GPT
eingegangen und durch diese Partnerschaft sollen Chat-GPT-Nutzerinnen weltweit
Zusammenfassungen ausgewählter Nachrichteninhalte von Axel Springers Medienmarken
erhalten, darunter Politico, Business Insider,
Bild und Welt, inklusive der sonst kostenpflichtigen Inhalte,
werden dann Quellenangaben, das heißt es gibt jetzt eine Live-Feed von Axel
Springer Müll in ChatGPT,
der dann da, sag ich mal,
mit reinfüttert.
Also was sie eigentlich damit sagen wollen ist, sie wollen ein paar Leute rausschmeißen
und dann können sie auch Kurscutting mit AI machen.
Das hatten sie ja vorher gesagt, der hat ja gesagt, der größere Teil, also ich mein,
das war auch glaube ich relativ klar, ich mein, dass das kreative Schaffensniveau
von Chachipiti, das einer durchschnittlichen Springer-Redakteurin überschreitet,
war jetzt nicht so schwer zu erkennen.
So dass es klar war, dass Axel Sprenger halt sagte, hier, pass auf,
ich glaube den größeren Teil von euch brauchen wir nicht mehr, ne?
Das ist schon völlig okay, ja.
Aber...
Sollen sie mal alle entlassen.
Alle entlassen und durch Grog ersetzen.
Genau, das ist nämlich dann ordentlich Vogue und dann wird auch Bild-Zeitung Vogue.
Und also sie kombinieren natürlich, wir wollen natürlich durch diese globale
Partnerschaft auch die Möglichkeiten des durch KI gestärkten Journalismus ausloten
und den unabhängigen Journalismus ins KI-Zeitalter retten.
Sagen wir mal, also mit dem unabhängigen Journalismus meinen sie wahrscheinlich
primär den Profit von Axel Springer und potenziell haben sie da tatsächlich
jetzt eine Chance oder haben sie da etwas getan,
was ich jetzt für ein Medienhaus nicht überraschend finde, dass es eine Partnerschaft
mit dieser eindeutig aktuell vorherrschenden Technologie eingehen.
Was dabei rauskommt, ob das zum Wohle Springer oder zum Wohle Chachipiti ist, werden wir sehen.
Zum Wohle der Allgemeinheit ist es mit Sicherheit nicht.
Also ich hatte auf jeden Fall gerade noch einen Ausschlag hier auf meinem Bullshit-O-Meter,
das war ziemlich deutlich gerade zu sehen.
Mal gucken wann wir dann aufhören für Chachipiti zu zahlen.
So, mit der Sendung müssen wir jetzt aber aufhören. Ich bin zu krank und du hast zu wenig Zeit.
Gibt's noch was zu sagen?
Nee, hast du jetzt schon gesagt.
Ja? Okay.
Krank, keine Zeit, Corona, Tim. Wie viele Mal Corona hast du?
Zweite Mal.
Zweite mal.
Ich höre eigentlich in diesem Jahr von allen, die es haben, dass es schlimmer ist.
Schlimmer?
Ja also die meisten sagen das ist, dass es diese zweite Erkrankung sie sehr
viel übler dahin rafft als die vielleicht erste, die sie vielleicht irgendwann 22 oder 21 hat.
Ja, weiß ich nicht, also bei mir ist ja, ist ein bisschen, hat ein bisschen
mehr Erkältungskarakter noch als beim ersten Mal.
Beim ersten Mal war es eigentlich eher, ja mindestens so eine kleine Husterei,
das war dann auch nach ein, zwei Tagen weg jetzt, so ein bisschen mehr Erkältungssymptome,
aber auch nichts was mich jetzt groß aus dem Konzept bringt.
Ich kann sogar noch einen Podcast machen hier nebenbei.
Und du bist ja jetzt auch isoliert in der Meta eben habe ich vernommen.
Genau. Endlich habe ich mal Zeit hier alles richtig fertig zu bauen, ist gut.
So komm, jetzt machen wir hier mal ein Ende.
Das war's. Logbuch Netzpolitik 479.
Wir sehen uns beim Kongress, hoffentlich.
Ja oder vielleicht auch vorher nochmal, vielleicht machen wir noch ne Sendung, mal gucken.
Ich meine dich doch nicht.
Was? Die anderen?
Ich meine jetzt die Hörerinnen und Hörer.
Ja, hab ich schon verstanden, hab ich schon verstanden. Hab ich schon verstanden.
Alles klar. Wir sagen tschüss, bis bald.
Wann ist der Moment, wo man aufhören muss in die Melodie reinzureden?
Äh, jetzt.
Okay, ciao, ciao.